Now, all these photos had been damaged by water, submerged in saltwater,...
...covered in bacteria, in sewage, sometimes even oil,...
...all of which, over time, is gonna continue to damage them,...
...so hand-cleaning them was a huge part of the project.
We couldn't retouch the photo unless it was clean, dry and reclaimed.
Now, we were lucky with our hand-cleaning.
We had an amazing local woman who guided us.
It's very easy to do more damage to those damaged photos.
After six months in Japan, 1,100 volunteers had passed through All Hands,...
...hundreds of whom had helped us hand-clean over 135,000 photographs.
Over 500 volunteers around the globe helped us get 90 families'...
...hundreds of photographs back, fully restored and retouched.
During this time, we hadn't really spent more than about a thousand dollars...
...in equipment and materials,...
...most of which was printer inks.
We take photos constantly.
A photo is a reminder of someone or something, a place, a relationship, a loved one.
They're our memory keepers in our histories,...
...the last thing we would grab and the first thing you'd go back to look for.
That's what this project was about,...
...about restoring those little bits of humanity, giving someone that connection back.